start churning butter and put on your
church shoes little sister because we're
about to blast off
I love you
now you sing now you don't would you
like some heroin
rootin tootin ready for shooting bearing
you waking our neighbors
look out right
that actually was pretty fun shape by
you you're like a brother to me
oh you're my best friend in the whole
world I don't think I'm your best friend
the whole world this might not be the
best idea reason I came to your neck in
space I mean there's a face in your neck
I mean what's Nicola West it's a good
group of boys we're all gonna die
together out here
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a part that is gone soon
okay bored man you wanna come over
please Joe I am NOT licking any white
dog I was the dog [ __ ] if you leave us
alone he's a real fat I swear I never do
this
hey girl she's my right-hand [ __ ] sorry
I mean in the dog way of being a [ __ ]
[Music]
I'm still here mother ups I got no
patience for this touchy-feely postive
I'm a short-tempered
son of a [ __ ]
I like to think of Jesus like with John
Eagles lands and singing lead vocals for
Lynyrd Skynyrd's with like an angel band
and I'm in the front row and I'm
hammered drunk hey Cal why you just shut
up yes ma'am